fair and true needs of the people of
teambridge
the commitment to social justice and
rightness
confidence
in what is honorable and fitting
the ability to work together in harmony
even when there is honest disagreement
and peace in their personal lives
and joy in their civic duties
and so we pray for the agenda set before
us today
grant us an assurance of what would
please you and what would benefit those
who live and work in and around team
bridge
we ask this
through jesus christ our lord
amen
thank you
thank you very much nick i do appreciate
it and i will say publicly thank you
very much for officiating at my civic
service on sunday thank you very much
nick i know you're a busy man so we'll
we'll let you go
thank you very much
right a few notes regarding the meeting
just to let you know that no fire alarm
test is planned and should the fire
alarm sound please leave the room at
your nearest exit
and meet at the far end of the car park
please raise your hand if you wish to
speak
and stay seated when speaking
please wait until abu microphone is
brought to you
you will not be heard on the live stream
otherwise
wear masks at all times unless you are
seated
keep points short
and i asked members
not to repeat points that i have ordered
that have already been raised
and voting will be by a show of hands
thank you
right item one on the agenda uh
apologies of absence could i have
apologies for absence please
i have counsellor austin can you hear me
councillor austin
councillor bradford
councillor haines councillor orm
councillor piet councillor persa and
councillor foden
thank you very much sarah
okay item two uh the minutes of the
council meeting on the 20th of september
2021 could i have a proposal please
councillor connect propose uh secondary
cancer due hirst
okay i see your hand that's uh cancer
patch
cancer patch
yes sorry
thank you thank you chair yes i've had a
look through the minutes i can't see any
reference to the supplementary questions
that were put by members of the public
and members of this council as you
understand it that those are actually
part of the business of the council i
would expect to see them in a minute so
i will move to defer acceptance of the
of the um minutes until they are
complete can i um just come in there
counter patch the minutes really are a
record of decisions that's the only
thing we can discuss they are not a
verbatim transcript of the meeting so as
such the meetings stand as they are
counselor eden
councillor eden in the front here please
thanks very much um yeah i've just got a
um a correction um you was just saying
um councillor parker that there are a
record of decisions
one of the decisions was to adjourn the
meeting after councillor gary taylor
arose from his seat and entered into an
altercation with uh councillor malone
and there's nothing at all in the
minutes about that which i find
an omission which is
not a good one okay thank you i'm just
going to defer to speak to the legal
person next to me please
uh the answer to that is when that took
place the meeting had already been
adjourned so it wasn't part of the
meeting
okay
um
i think these are these are ridiculous
and weasel words i think if we've got a
a video online which shows very
definitely that the meeting was
adjourned after that altercation took
place and after councillor taylor had
launched himself at council malone i
think at the very least we ought to
record the fact that there was an
adjournment that's just a matter of fact
and history
just bear with me a second
i i think i've made my point we're going
to move on i've addressed it so please
we're not going to go any further with
the minutes so we have a proposer cancer
connie
so can we please go to the vote please
point of order councillor doles
uh i i understand that uh
excuse me councillors can i ask a viewer
point of order what what rule are you
talking about has been broken uh the
point of order is that councillor patch
uh put forward a motion uh to defer the
minute so he could remind me uh and i'm
seconding that so uh i think that
probably needs to go to the vote uh and
i think what you can do is airbrush out
of history that an assault occurred
during a meeting and not record it
i'm sorry we're going to move on to that
we're not we're not going to take that
we've got a proposal for the minutes
we're going to have the minutes voted on
it proposed by cancer connect seconded
by cancer jihadist can we go to the vote
please all those in favor of accepting
the minutes
that's
any against
obviously
any abstentions
in one extension thank you very much
that is
two abstentions right
i can see too that's carried
okay i i have a few announcements to
make item three on the agenda
firstly i'd like to
bring to the council's notice that a a
woodland in teen bridge known as the
perridge estate which is near long down
in exeter
uh it's won an award in
the resilience award for the existing
woodlands in the all england it is the
winner of that award jointly and a
letter has been has been sent by myself
on behalf of the council
to congratulate the owner of that
woodland sir harry studholm on that
award uh and its respect of climate
change and developing species that are
resistant to climate change so that is
an excellent situation and um
congratulations and our letter will be
going on behalf of the council from
myself
now at this time we're going to receive
a statement from
councillor taylor and this statement is
purely that it is a statement that is
not open up for debate so a short
statement from councillor taylor please
thank you thank you chair uh members of
the council i come before you today to
offer my sincere apologies
for my part in what occurred at the last
meeting of this council
whilst my actions were intended to
prevent an escalation of an ongoing
situation
i recognize that in a in the field of
politics there is no place for physical
confrontation however well-intentioned
or otherwise
you have my word that i will not act in
this manner again in the future
thank you
thank you councillor taylor as i said
that's just a statement so we'll move on
um another announcement um regarding the
agenda i intend to change item 18 and 19
the other way around so
the motion notice emotions will come
before canceller questions and that is
at the end of the agenda notice emotions
will come before cancer questions thank
you
item 4 on the agenda
declarations of interest
councillor patch
thank you chair
this is something obviously that i
raised with you last night and not
having had any guidance i'm having to
make a judgment call on putting these
declarations of interest in the public
domain
i am at present engaged in a legal
action against team british district
council on behalf of whom mr paul
woodhead is acting
that means i believe i have a
declaration of interest with relation to
item number eight
on the on today's agenda the appointment
of the monitoring officer
having looked at the guidance on the
members code of conduct and declarations
um that should be made in terms of
pecuniary interests i can't see that
although i have a financial interest in
the outcome of that legal case
as being handled by mr paul woodhead i
don't see that listed as a pecuniary
interest that would prevent me from
taking part in that item
i'm happy to be advised otherwise
secondly with respect to the same item
i think it's so that i should declare
that i have submitted a complaint for
breach of the officer's code of conduct
against mr paul woodhead
again i do not think that prevents me
from taking part in the item discussion
of number eight but i shan't vote on
that to be to be sure
thank you councillor patch that's
something you obviously declared and we
can discuss under item 8 you have
declared it at this time thank you for
that declaration
right moving on now to item 5 which is
public questions and we did have one
public question from mr andrew malcolm
from the alexander theater
he's not represent you've probably seen
the question and it has been answered in
writing
but mr malcolm is not here presence to
ask any supplementaries so we will move
on at this stage
item six
is the final accounts and governance
and the executive member for corporate
services would will present this item
counselor keeling
thank you mr chairman colleagues
i would first like to thank martin
flincroft and his team for working with
grant thornton's
this statement of accounts has been very
taxing for the team
as the regulator has requested more
information
for grant thornton's to look into and
report
in summary
we have
as of 31st march 2021
general reserves of
2.06 million which is a significant
improvement on the original budget of
eighty thousand pounds
may i point out future risks around
future funding from government and the
adequacy of reserves going forward
as further action may be required to
address the continuing impact of kovid
19 pandemic and budget gaps
other considerations you will hear from
julie massey grant thornton's is the
issue on property plant and equipment
valuations and evidence to substantiate
those valuations which the estates team
and our finance team are happy with
further on the agenda
in item 10
the new financial system will help
improve availability of information to
our external auditor grant thornton
which they support
i conclude that this administration took
action when needed for the front line
services to continue for the well-being
of teams residents
so i propose mr chairman that the
council resolves to a approve the 2020
21 statement of accounts including the
annual governance statement and letter
of representation as recommended by the
audit scrutiny committed subject to a
final adjustment agreement with the
external
auditors to be reported to council and b
note the audit fining report from grant
thornton and approve the action arising
from the action plan
c note the mid-year review of treasury
management for
2021-22 as recommended by the executive
on the 2nd of november
mr chairman can i now pass you over to
council morgan chair of audit scrutiny
thank you country morgan
thank you chair yes i'm happy to second
this it's been scrutinized at all it's
crucial uh across party uh committee um
i'd just like to say thank you to the
staff who've had an awful amount of
extra work to do this last 18 months
so i'm very happy to second this
thank you councillor morgan now at this
time i'd like to pass over to julie
massey i hope i've pronounced that right
to give us an address some details on
the final accounts julie it's over there
mr chairman thank you very much indeed
and good morning councillors um so the
report you have in front of you today um
follows on from the report we presented
at the audit scrutiny committee um last
month and gives an update to the
outcomes of the financial statements
audit audit
as you'll pick up from page 23 of your
papers page three of my reports um it
has been a difficult year for the
council
recognizing the continuing challenges
that covert has brought
and as a result of that we've had to do
a lot of our work
remotely
now there has been some
issues around the ability of the finance
system to give us information in the
format we need we are moving forward
very much in a digital way as far as our
audit is concerned and it's recognized
that the the council needs to invest in
its financial systems to improve the
data that is presented as part of the
audit so and absolutely welcome um
councillor keelan's point about the item
later in this agenda
around the implement implementation of a
new finance management system and that
absolutely will support improvements in
the information that's prepared to
support the audit process
has has been highlighted there are no
significant issues arising to date from
the audit with the exception of that uh
highlighted in relation to the valuation
of property plant and equipment
there's been a continuous
level of
increasing work around estimates in the
accounts and your property valuations
are a significant part of that in fact
it's the biggest item on your balance
sheet and so
as your auditors we're required to look
at that in some detail not just looking
at the valuation reports provided by
your experts but also all of the
detailed assumptions that underpin that
and we need to be able to evidence that
to third party source data to make sure
we understand where those assumptions
have come from
so whilst we are satisfied that there
are clearly valuation reports that
support your valuations in the accounts
where we've been having some challenges
is around actually evidence and the the
underlying detailed assumptions that
support those valuations
based on where we are at the moment
as far as the audit is concerned we
would be proposing a qualification of
the audit opinion around those
valuations because we do not
at the moment feel that we have
sufficient information to support those
valuations
that process needs to go through quite a
detailed moderation within grant
thornton it's really important to
highlight that property valuations is an
area of significant judgment and
subjectivity which is why we need to
give it a lot of focus
but it's also important to say that a
qualification is not taken lightly it's
an option of last resort and we have to
make sure that we've explored all
possible avenues with officers to see
whether there is any information that
can be provided to us before we reach
that final conclusion
but we do recognize it's been a very
challenging um period for for officers
across the authority and indeed
resources within the estates team have
been
reduced at this late at this stage of
the audit and so
um it's obviously there's a finite
amount of resource that that can
support this
so we will
continue to work with officers over the
over the coming days to see what we can
do to resolve this matter but it's just
really to highlight to this this council
that if we're not in a position that we
can
seek that additional evidence then that
will be the proposed way forward as far
as the audit is concerned
i think it's also important to highlight
that this is not something that's just
that is being experienced by by team
bridge council it's an area as i said
that requires a lot of scrutiny and
indeed we are seeing evidence of such
challenges at other authorities as well
because of the level of work we have to
do around these specific assumptions
but we're very much working with the
estates team to make sure that for the
valuations process for next year that
improvements are already starting to be
put in place so this issue doesn't
reoccur
for the future
outside of the property valuations
you'll see that we've highlighted some
other
recommendations in our audit report
those have been fully accepted by by
management
and it's pleasing to also note that
whilst there have been some adjustments
to the accounts that you have in front
of you at this at this meeting
those
are mostly of a disclosure nature and
none of those affect either the reserves
or the reported position of this council
so chair mr chairman i will i'll leave
my report at um at that point but happy
to take any specific questions before it
goes to a vote
thank you julie um councillor russell
question
put your hand up in the third place
regarding the property evaluations
particularly in the areas of devon and
cornwall are you valuable valuing up or
down
thank you
um it's it's it's a bit of both so
depending on the nature of the the
properties um properties will go up and
down
so for example um a lot of some assets
are valued on a on an income basis and
because of the reduced levels of income
that have been generated during the
covert period some of those valuations
have gone down in some cases some
properties still managed to weather the
storm of the economic conditions fairly
well and are still seeing some increases
so there's no one-size-fits-all it's
it's a bit of a mixture thank you very
much thank you thank you cancer bullet
behind you behind you
thank you very much i note on page 34
that the
council's pension deficit has grown by
21.447 million
since its last revision
which is obviously a concerning increase
and i appreciate that this is down to uh
actuarial valuations
the
pension fund i understand is invested
with the devon pension scheme which
doesn't show such a deterioration in its
funds or short warning funds can you
tell me what the implications are for
the council having this increased
deficit within its pension from
portfolio
so i think it's important to highlight
there's two two aspects of pension fund
valuations that counsellors should be
aware of there's an accounting valuation
that's done for
the purposes of the year-end account so
effectively the act the actuary comes in
at the end of each year and does a
position statement to
make sure that the valuation that's in
the council's accounts complies with the
accounting standards
that's separate to the funding valuation
that the actuary does on a three-year
basis which informs the level of
contributions that are set that this
authority effectively has to pay um
towards pensions so whilst on on paper
it looks quite a significant uh
increase in the liability that will not
affect the levels of contributions the
authority will need to effectively pay
from its budget because that is set at
the start of the three year period
from the separate fund evaluation that's
conducted by the actuary to inform the
the level of contribution rates that are
that are set so actuarial assumptions
jump up and down or
all the time and so this is just to
reflect the accounting requirements of
of is 19
which shows a sort of snapshot at a
point in time at in in the accounts of
the authority but that will not affect
your contribution levels um that will be
then reassessed um based on the fund
position of the fund as a whole um every
every three years so that fundamental
evaluation i think is is due in another
18 months two years time so
financially to you there's no impact of
those um uh assumptions moving around at
the moment that will be driven by the
next triangle evaluation in a couple
years time i don't know if martin wants
to add anything more into that
martin flickcraft
can we just just pause her a little bit
more and i think there's not quite
catching all of that so can we just
restart that nothing generally to add
what judy said around the 18 months in
18 months time we'll know about the next
tri-annual evaluation which will
determine what we
what we actually pay in terms of a
percentage contribution year on year and
there's a deficit contribution as well
which is adjusted to reflect what's
going on generally around economic
conditions um life expectancy and a
number of other things so that's that
situation as we are thank you
thank you very much um we have cancer
doors at the back
thank you he's already there yeah yeah
thank you thanks very much the uh
i was wondering if within the accounts
given that team bridge district council
has a habit of making quarter of a
million payoffs to uh
2x employees without disclosing the full
details why whether there are any uh
payments of of any scale can counsel
doors can i ask when you ask a question
don't don't make a speech about other
items just ask a question please i i i
refer you to the human rights act and my
freedom of expression
and as i ask a question
i don't think i can be told how to frame
that question
i'll carry on so i would like to know if
there are any uh items in the account in
relation to ex ratio payments to former
employees or should we be looking out
for those in the next set of accounts
thank you
can you answer that julie
or martin
if not
so we're just trying to find the note to
the accounts one second
just bear with us
can i just at this time ask all cancers
when they're asking a question please
come to the point and ask the questions
a reasonable period not to preamble
can you go with the microphone please
yes in terms of um
officers remuneration and extra packages
they appear every year in the accounts
they are public knowledge and they're
currently note 33 in the accounts on
pages 86
87
and page
88 going on to 89 so all the information
is there thank you
thank you mr whitcroft thank you very
much
as i can't see any other hands raised i
don't believe so um councillor bullivant
can i just
microphone
can i ask a confirmation please that the
council has always adhered to the terms
of terms of contract for employees
um at their point of when they've left
this council
could you repeat the question is it
possible to confirm that the council has
always adhered to the contractual terms
that employees enjoy at the point of
time which they've left this council
can you pick that up martin
or tim
thank you tim
uh yes i can confirm that any
contractual issues are dealt with in
terms of any exit of staff from the
council
thank you thank you very much as we have
no other speakers we have a proposal for
the acceptance of the accounts from
cancer keeling and it was seconded by
councillor morgan can we please now go
to the vote all those in favor
against
abstentions
thank you very much that is carried
thank you very much
thank you very much julie
right if we now be moving to item seven
and item seven i would like to move and
recommend that under section 100a of the
local government act 1972 the press and
public be excluded from the meeting
during the consideration of the
following item on the grounds that it
involves the likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraphs one
and two
relates to an individual of part one of
schedule 12a of the act i'd like to
propose that we do that can i have a
secondary please
counselor connect thank you very much
we'll move in part two now can i ask the
public to remove themselves please
oh can i go to the vote please sorry
those against
that's carried any abstentions
all right thank you that's carried and
we will move into part two and in
respect of your comments at the back uh
members of the public's questions i'd
just like some clarification on the
reason why those uh members of the
public who are turned up expecting to
hear their um questions um answered or
indeed read um have been disappointed in
that and um it seems there was some
issue with the the date or time by which
questions were submitted
um i'm not i'm not sure
to my reading the constitution is very
clear and the difference between clear
working days and working days for um
timetabled sub submission of questions
and it seems to me on the information
i've seen they submitted their questions
on time so i'd like some clarification
on why they were rejected the decision
was made their their questions were not
submitted within the two days and they
were told of that fact and they had
still arrived expecting to ask those
questions so they were informed
previously that the questions would not
be allowed because they were within the
two days so they were not before the end
of the two days so that is the reason
that's the ruling and that's my ruling
councilor patch so sorry that is the
explanation okay at least one man the
public says they were not informed they
were actually told their question was
exactly i'm sorry that's that's my
ruling we won't go any further with that
one thank you
right thank you very much uh i presume
we're live streaming again
thank you
oh i didn't see your hand
cancer patch that's winter patch oh
cancer doors counselor door sorry my
point of order i had noticed you uh
invited paul woodhead back in which is
uh right and proper now it's part one uh
could we invite the other members of the
public are still waiting outside uh back
into the meeting please uh it's not for
me to invite them if they wish to return
they may how how are they going to know
that they
they may come back in as long as they
act in a suitable manner thank you very
much
you have somebody here who's being voted
on to the standards committee who's
actually stood outside uh i think you
should have the politeness and manners
to invite them back into the room
they are perfectly entitled to come back
in how are they going to know that the
meeting has restarted
they have been asked
thank you
related first but totally unrelated
what breach are we talking about um um
the the actual um who controls what
members are speaking um i noticed that
um towards the end of my last um item
um the person administering the camera
told the the person with the microphone
to move away and so that i would not be
on the record i just wonder what
authority he has in directing the
proceedings of this meeting
we thought it had been finished that's
that's it to apologize if that was the
impression that's something that really
meant to happen okay
right so congratulations to paul um
appointment to remove um
monitoring officer congratulations
okay
um now we can move on to item 10
which is the new financial management
system could i go over to the executive
member for corporate services counselor
keeling
thank you mr chairman colleagues
as the report explains the in-house
system is no longer sustainable in this
present climate the new proposed
financial system will create much needed
efficiencies and enhance reporting
capabilities while making savings
we will be automating more processes so
that the creditors and ordering is
faster so reducing printing costs our
financial admin can carry out our tasks
rather than strata saving support costs
from strata
improving faster availability of
information as you heard from our
external auditor to our external audit
so making savings
mr chairman we have previously approved
this cost in february 2020
budget
this financial management system
investment shows that team bridges
forward thinking working with exeter
city council east devon district council
being better equipped for the challenges
ahead
making savings long term for the
residents of team bridge i propose the
council resolves to one approve the
proposed capital budget of 267 000
pounds for the replacement of the
current financial management system and
any assorted
associated systems linked to the
financial management system
thank you mr chairman
thank you cancer keeling can i have a
secondary to that i've got a few there
councillor morgan
thank you very much um we have any
comments uh
cancer parker khan
over to the left here please microphone
thank you um i think it's a good move to
go to this
new more efficient integrated system my
question is around any additional costs
that haven't been factored in here
particularly i'm looking at um the
strata and it says here that the um
there is the result of eliminating
internal staffing support from strata
are there going to be any redundancy
implications there that would have a
cost implication to the council
okay thank you parker chancellor khan
cancer keeling or do you would like me
to ask
mr flickroft
microphone if we could right keeping you
busy
in terms of
strata we have one programmer that um
solely supports the financial management
system so in terms of keeping the
existing system running that's that's a
clear risk but we understand that
over the next two or three years as we
get this system implemented
um that person will be able to then work
on other convergence projects and other
schemes that have got the type in the in
the pipeline so that's my understanding
of that person's role going forward
thank you mr mclaughlin android question
country morgan
yeah um
thank you chair i'm happy to second this
um
obviously it's it's long overdue and
very much welcome
it will make our
financial system much more flexible and
more robust particularly in the the
current climate we're living at the
moment where we have to rely on a lot of
remote working as well and obviously
it's going to be something that will be
subject to audit scrutiny looking at
very carefully thank you
thank you councillor morgan uh
councillor hocking at the back there
yeah thank you chair um just a very
simple question really um tdc obviously
acts as payroll officers for
several other little organizations
including town council um will this
impact on how they perform that task and
if it does will there be any additional
cost to the
the people that they're doing the tasks
for okay
mr vicroft
easy answer that is no because the
payroll system that we've got already
installed is going to um sort out any
any payroll going forward so that's not
none of that not affected at all
thank you thank you very much um
there was one other question council
wrigley but i think you've you know
dissolved that so thank you no other
questions
uh we have a proposal from cancer
keeling seconded by councillor morgan
can we go to the vote please all those
in favor
against
abstentions
okay thank you very much that's carried
okay thank you very much if we can move
on to item eleven
and that's recommendation from executive
uh regarding driver and operational
staff and the executive member for
recycling
councillor jewhorst
i'm sure that you like so many residents
in our district have been incredibly
grateful to our waste team who've turned
out in all weathers and throughout the
pandemic to keep our district waste and
litter free
do you thank you
due to national issues there has been a
huge hgv driver shortage this has meant
that the larger transport companies have
offered ever-increasing incentives to
tempt drivers to work for them and this
has worked its way through the chain to
reach us here in team bridge
you will be pleased to know that we have
market forces policies in place to deal
with this so that it does not impact on
our ability to deliver a first-rate
service for the people of team bridge
the budget implication of this proposal
is 80 000 in this current financial year
and 240 000 in a full year the
supplement is only payable whilst there
is an ongoing rationale and will be
regularly reviewed
as a good council we need to pay our
workforce fairly executive recommended
this to council on the 2nd of november
and i therefore propose to council that
you approve this driver an operational
staff salary change thank you chair
thank you seconded by councillor connect
thank you very much
uh
cancer parker khan
you just put your hand up so
thank you they're coming
thank you um i agree with councilly
junehurst our teams have done a
fantastic job and it's absolutely right
that we pay them properly and sorry
that's a bit of preamble but it's
necessary to say
my query is around the um the cost again
to the council and how that's going to
be managed i know that it says it will
create
budget pressure um and we'll look at the
proposals in december for next year
um but my concern is how those costs
which are significant 80 000 pounds are
going to be managed this year and what
the implications are as to where the
money is going to come from is it from a
cut from elsewhere are we going to eat
into reserves or where is that money
going to come from
and also if i'm allowed to ask as well
about the market forces supplements if
we feel that we should be paying our
drivers properly surely we should be
increasing their salary per se rather
than as a temporary thing just as an
uplift because of market forces i think
it's something we should pay our staff
properly
thank you thank you country student to
come back on that just in front of you
thank you in in terms of of the market
forces uh to take your second question
first in terms of market forces uh
clearly they're going to be ongoing and
therefore we will be continuing uh to
pay in terms of where the money comes
from i'm afraid uh i think we need to go
over to uh mr flickcraft our uh finance
manager uh to explain where where that
240
or 80 000
the figure is in fact eighty thousand
two hundred and ninety pounds for this
year yeah
mr flick craft behind you
yes in terms of the last budget report
that we took to executive on the second
of november we indicated that there was
a saving this year of just over seven
hundred thousand pounds so effectively
the eighty thousand pounds cost is going
to push that back to about 620 and then
the 240 ongoing year after year
i'm looking at as part of the overall um
budget papers for
um back end of december and the initial
budget proposal so that they'll form
part of the overall exercise
i'll be doing savings exercises as well
corporately to try and balance the
budget so it'll come out in the wash as
part of that thank you
thank you mr croft councillor cox put
your hand up councillor cox
it's very nice to have compliments about
our waste teams from members of the
public who do constantly say that and i
hope everyone will give a christmas box
to our refuge collectors um but um we're
asking where the money should come from
perhaps government might be prepared to
um and perhaps those of a certain
political persuasion in this council
chamber could write to the government
and say give us a fair amount we've lost
60 pence in every pound and uh so we do
need to pay our
sorry i've been been collectors a fair
wage but we need to do that without
putting up the council tax for people
and perhaps the government as they take
a massive interest in uh refuge
collections and set rules etc perhaps
they might like to give a bit of money
towards towards the cost
thank you cancer cox
okay
um
no other questioners i can say so we had
a proposal from cancer jewhurst seconded
by councillor connet can we go to the
vote please all those in favor
against
abstentions
no abstentions so fine that is carried
uh most welcome decision i'm sure thank
you very much
right if we can now move on to item 12
and before we do i'll just say we will
due to have a short break in a while so
we can people can have a cup of coffee
and just just a break okay i will i will
announce that shortly but if we can go
to item 12
and that's a recommendation from the
deputy chair of licensing and regularity
that's councillor hayes
yes thank you chair good morning
councillors i'd like to present to this
council the review of the statements of
principles under the gambling act 2005
section 23 policy
and this review is necessary every three
years and was last approved in november
2018 and is a requirement if tdc's to
continue to be a licensed authority
this was reviewed by the full licensing
regular committee and was approved
unanimously on the 23rd of october this
year so i'd like to propose acceptance
of the standards of principles for this
gambling act 2005
for the period 31st of january 2022 to
the 30th of january 2025 to this council
thank you general thank you councillors
councillor russell
council russell secondart thank you very
much are there any other comments
if not oh we'll go to the vote all those
in favor
against abstentions
that's carried thank you very much
since that went through quite quickly
we'll do the next item um item 13 and
that's a recommendation from audit
scrutiny counselor sally morgan
thank you i'll be very brief because
this is a recommendation from the
cross-party audit scrutiny i'd like to
recommend to full council the revision
of the financial thresholds within the
contract procedure rules be approved as
stated in table 2 of 3.7 of the report
this basically brings us up to
current reasonable levels
without having to go to
approval every time obviously
financial thresholds and contracts are
audited and
scrutinized anyway
this um
i think i'd like to ask councillor
rolison to comment as deputy chair he
actually uh chaired this meeting uh
where the decision was made thank you
thank you cancer rolison
thank you chair um
sally's adequately outlined that the
paper i chaired the meeting it went
through due scrutiny i was impressed by
the quality of the questions quality of
the answers and particularly i think the
research from offices was excellent with
extensive benchmarking and the rationale
and the benefits are clearly set out in
the paper therefore i would if it's not
being seconded i'll second it but i
certainly support the uh the council in
accepting the recommendation thank you
thank you councillor ryerson
cannot see any other members wishing to
speak so if that's the case we'll go to
the vote it's been proposed and seconded
all those in favor
against
abstentions
okay that's carried thank you very much
we'll cover one more item before we have
a a break
and this is a recommendation from
standards committee uh could we have the
chairman to present this please
i can't see where she is councillor
federick
do apologize couldn't see you there
thank you chair following the resolution
by full council
on 23rd of november 2020
to appoint town or paris representative
on standards committee
a recruitment exercise has been
undertaken to fill this role
after a robust interview process
sheila brooke and jane taylor were
offered the role and therefore the
council is asked to approve these
appointments i propose has set out
thank you thank you very much could i
have a second to please
question okay thank you seconded by
cancer cancer connect council eden
you've got a question
hand up please you have no boom
you need two rushing towards you now
thank you yeah just just a quick
question um what specific an accredited
training in terms of diversity
unconscious bias and equalities has been
lined up for these two new members
um can we go back to cancer patrick she
has her hand up thank you
specific and accredited
okay thank you
and once these are approved we will be
looking at setting out a training
program and that's what's been told to
both applicants
that doesn't answer my question about
what the training is though
well we will be looking at the training
once it's been approved
the appropriate training
so all i'm asking for it's a simple
question is for confirmation that there
will be specific and accredited training
in terms of diversity unconscious bias
and equalities
the answer to that is yes super thank
you very much great okay
we have cancer hook
thanks chair
can i ask if this appointment or these
appointments rather are for the duration
of this municipal year
whether they're for
the duration of this administration um
whether they're for eternity
how long are they appointed for
i think the answer to that if um kansas
pedric has not known it is two years
appointments
reconsiderations anyway
okay
thank you no more hands up i don't
believe
so it's been proposed and seconded that
we approved these two appointments all
those in
favor against
could i please have
a bit of silence at the back please
uh i think we said all those and
abstentions please
one abstention thank you very much that
is carried i'd like to now move that we
um have a break
for 15 minutes
i make the time i know there's a clock
around the corner there
a few minutes after 11 so if we can come
back at just after a quarter past 11
please and you are welcome to coffees
one pound ago streaming i presume
thank you if we could
resume at
item 15 which
pl please we are in the meeting
we could resume at item 15
which is recommendation from procedures
committee um
late information replanning committee
and this was the committee that i'm
chair of so
[Music]
an item 15 two items
we recommend to the full council that
all councillors be reminded that the
deadline for submission of new
information on planning applications
being considered by the planning
committee is two clear working days
prior to the date of the meeting and no
later
and recommendation two is
all any new information or submissions
regarding planning applications should
be submitted to the planning email
address planning at teambridge.gov dot
uk
by two clear working days prior to the
meeting those are the two
recommendations i have been here before
and went back to the procedures and
they've come back again so they're here
for your approval
and i so propose those
seconded by councillor connect
councillor patch
thank you um this does raise a question
or two chair but in particular what um
happens if evidence or submissions
should come to light within those
two clear working days um
the information that might be in the
public domain
might even have been submitted to the
planning portal
then
this obviously doesn't address what
might happen in that situation i i think
this goes back to the the problem with
this that um rather than coming from a
full and thorough review of planning
procedures
these are just um items that have been
tacked on to the end of a standards
hearing a case that was um constructed
against myself with regard to a
complaint
um
the these don't make any sense they're
not workable i think if
if there are
if there is a proper review of planning
procedures
that is considered and looks at the
whole of the procedures and issues that
there might be in those procedures
particularly with regard to late
submissions and and putting submissions
in front of the planning committee then
i think that's all well and good let
there be a review
don't let's just try and tack something
on to pretend that this issue of
planning procedures has been looked at
so i know i know full well that this is
only coming forward in this format
due to a wish to disregard
complaints against planning procedures
so as to instead put those issues into a
constructed standards case against
myself i think i think we're straying a
bit there cancer and getting a little
bit personal so i'm sorry um we uh yeah
um in in respect of items that come
forward within the two days it would be
a judgment call by officers as to
whether they would be uh
sufficient enough to restrict that being
put to that agenda or whether they were
of little consequence just a matter of
changing dates uh amounts etc that would
be acceptable within that period so
if if you councillor patch wished to uh
put forward a motion uh put forward an
idea that a full review of the planning
committee then is certainly something we
could do but that's something that would
go to the procedures committee for that
review before it comes to council and we
do hope to do a procedures committee
meeting again very soon not arranged but
will be soon um country mcgregor
thank you chair um i just wanted to
follow the the similar line about the
the time scales that are involved we
recently had a planning application come
to committee at very short notice
uh with a site visit the week before
um
and
subsequent to finding out that it was
being included onto the uh the agenda
for planning with there was a discovery
of
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
pages of technical information that had
been added
prior to the the arrangement of the
agenda
now from the perspective of an
opportunity to
review that documentation and then come
up with a submission it's unlikely that
we would be able with very very short
notice agenda additions like that to
meet that criteria
and i think on the basis of that i think
putting a fixed
time scale in
and also leaving it to the um
judgment of officers who are
to be fair expected and and required
within the nppf um to uh
get developments
through the system so
you know i i i would suggest that in a
situation where it's a short notice that
that is suspended i would recommend that
as an amendment
to this particular uh set of clauses
yeah
i think we we've this has come to this
committee and it has been proposed by
myself and seconded i'm quite willing to
put the same point to you so as cancer
patch that if a proposal to review the
whole system comes for discussion at
procedures we're quite willing to do
that for the future but at this time i
think these these these proposals do
stand
uh i'm not
sure francesca patch is a quick one
please because i normally do not want
them
i've got others i'd like to take take
your lead chair and propose an amendment
um to this motion that um these items
are deferred until such time is a full
and thorough um review of planning
procedures has taken place
that's my that's my proposal in case
there's anyone who might say that that's
seconded by cancer mcgregor okay
councillor
cox um i do take the point that council
patch makes but i think we should pass
these today and i think perhaps add that
there is a full and thorough uh review
of the planning procedures uh councillor
mcgregor mentioned about a planning app
uh if you you very kindly allowed me as
a neighbouring ward member and the
county councillor to speak
obviously some of that information was
in the pub
there before two days it is very
difficult because officers have to
respond
to quite complex issues so i think we
should pass these today but also add a
third uh
third issue of full and thorough um ask
the
procedures committee to do a full and
thorough look at the procedures that we
do with planning applications we need to
be fair to the public but we need to be
fair to you know hard-working officers
who need to respond and that item was
deferred because councillors were not
satisfied that enough information had
been uh
provided for that uh it gives the
opportunity for the town council to look
again at the legalities of the
procedures which we will be doing um so
i think we should pass what is there
today i accept this it is a tack on but
it is the right thing to do and when we
can have a full and full look at the
whole procedure to give to be fair to
both officers and objectors i understand
what you're saying kenzie cox cancer
connie
thank you chairman i'd ask council to
support the two recommendations um and
in terms of
deferral what i'm hearing is that the
system is working
that if members of the planning
committee feel that there was too much
new information that they didn't have
time to consider and officers had not
had time to
go through and make a recommendation to
council clearly the planning committee
had the power to defer anyway so the
system is working and what this does is
set out for members
the ideal of the submission of any new
information on planning applications two
days in advance
in my view chairman the recommendations
from the
procedures committee are fine as they
are and if there is a view that the
council needs to consider again its
whole procedures for planning that
should come through perhaps through a
motion to the next council and let
council then consider that in the proper
way so i would resist any amendment and
support one and two thank you chairman
okay councillor patch
thank you i'd just like to reply to
councillor connie's
assertion that the system is working
quite clearly in the planning meeting of
july 2020 planning committee meeting the
system did not work because the officer
did not bring to the attention of the
committee
information that perhaps might have been
brought to their attention
because it was i think we're strange
another issue please against me um i
think we will draw hope to that now
there has been a proposal to an
amendment by yourself and seconded by
councillor mcgregor
we'll go to that vote first that was to
defer this uh for future discussion now
all those in favor to
defer please can you have silence at the
back please please
i'm
asking you to be
quiet
i'm not
going to ask you again i'm asking you
very very
thank you
right i had a proposal to defer from
cancer patch seconded by councillor
mcgregor those in favor of deferral
please
those against deferral
any abstentions
right
we know goat
that's lost so we go back to the main
item which was a proposal on these two
items uh i propose this seconded by
councillor connect all this and all
those in favor
no no he did not
no
i please
no that's there was no further proposal
i don't believe it
this is something that we dealt with
through procedures and it will come back
from receiving your good officers chair
if we can have this up procedures then
we can look at whether we need to do a
review
yeah thank you so
cancer parker calm
no not at this time
okay
it will be dealt with under procedures
in procedures
so
i want to move on please we've had a
proposal we've had a secondary all those
in favor that we accept these two as
they stand
against
please
against
abstentions please
i've been very lenient allowing you to
come back in and interruptions
i'm not going to allow any more
interruptions otherwise i shall adjourn
the meeting again
thank you
no you cannot please you cannot
right that is carried thank you
what rule are you point of order please
it's a request for clarification you
just said that it will be handed by the
procedures what will be handled by the
procedures committee
there is nothing to be debated cancer
patch in that case what were you
referring when and this will be on the
record you you asserted that something
will be handed handled by the discussion
will be handed to procedures committee
which discussion
just bear with us a second
we're just moving on because the vote
with vote has been passed so that's
we're going no further with that i'm
going to move on now to item 16 and
that's another recommendation from the
procedures committee
and it is that
there's two items two parts to this
members and parish councils can request
that applications to vary conditions
including legal aspects to be called in
to planning committee in line with
council's usual process
and
a report on variations to conditions for
major applications that have been
approved be placed on the planning
committee for information i move those
proposals second by councillor connect
all those in favor
against
abstentions
thank you that is
passed
we now move on to item 17
which is the committee seats allocation
i'd like to pass over to the leader
councillor connect
chairman following uh formation of a new
group on the council on adjustments in
uh
proportional entitlements the report is
before council for its approval and also
separately on a separate piece of paper
uh various committee membership changes
have been advised to the council for its
noting thank you chairman i move
thank you can i have a here please
counselor mcgregor
thank you
uh all those in favor oh counselor patch
you have your hand up
thank you and i must thank the
microphone operator to be on hand he's
obviously got an idea whether where the
scrutiny is coming from in this council
um
i'd like to make the point um that i do
realize that calculations have been
provided that
might might be used in making these
allocations on committee seats i'll also
point to president where an individual
member not within a group has been
provided with committee seats
in this um within this last three years
i'm just um like to register my
disappointment that i'm not on the
planning committee anymore according to
this or indeed any other committees
although i'm sure there will be signs of
relief amongst um certain perhaps
officers and members
at that decision
i note councillor patch's disappointment
and request the council to support the
recommendations thank you
thank you
right cancer doors
hi i'd like to put forward an amendment
that uh councillor patch is allocated a
seat uh as indeed councillor eden was
when she stepped out of the lib dem
group so
if anyone would care to second that
amendment
seconded by cancer malone
i don't know what you're putting your
hand up for
and no comment please
no sorry you're not
no
however proposal of amendment that
cancer patch b allocated place on the
planning committee seconded by
councillor malone that is an amendment
we'll go to the vote all those in favor
hold on
cancer
it's a proportional allocation so if
councillor dawes is proposing that
cancer patches on the planning committee
is he offering that councillor patch
takes one of the newton says no seats on
planning
because it's a proportional allocation
so if the proposal is for cancer patch
to be placed onto planning i think we
need to hear from
officers on what the proportional impact
of that is what the entitlement to a
place is
thank you chairman
thank you it's the managing director
thank you chairman um in accordance with
local government rules and regulations
we appoint uh based on the
proportionality of each party within it
so consequently as an independent
independent councillor patch will be
entitled to 147 of a seat on a committee
so what if it's a planning committee
with 17 members or if there's an ons
with 11 members or whatever the group
sorry whatever the committee is it's
147th of that proportionality
the situation um is therefore correct as
the leader says which is consequently if
you're proposing that councillor patch
has a seat on there somebody else won't
get a seat on there one of the other
groups because the size of the committee
is finite
so it would have to be recalculated each
time that the groups move around there
is another calculation so consequently
with councillor eden becoming
independent that was slightly different
in terms of proportionality of the rest
of the
rest of the at the council
so each time we will reassess it in line
with what the government government
risks are
councillor eden
just to say i'm happy to step off
planning to allow councillor patch to be
on it it's fine by me
is is that something that we can allow
we're just uh
just bear with us a second
sorry chairman can we just check can i
just check the um
no no in terms of the new
[Music]
yes i i take the notes on
proportionality and uh the the
0.047 being close to over 50. uh i think
it'd probably be very reasonable then to
look at uh what proportionality uh
carries across all of the groups on the
representation on planning
and see which
which groups carry a greater
representation
in a mathematical sense and then that
party should step aside
one
one member and allow the independent uh
to have a voice and represent his
electorate and the residents of his ward
councillor connect you wanted to come
back chairman uh as i understand it uh
the calculations work out as they do
i understand entirely what council dawes
has suggested but there is no
entitlement to cancel a patch uh i move
that the question is now put and invite
councillor to support the committee seat
allocation is set out in the report
okay that has been moved by cancer
connor i believe it was second did i
come
oh cancel him alone i didn't
right beside you
um
however the equations work on this and i
appreciate this is what the maths say
but
if it's calculated in such a way that a
true independent as in somebody who is a
party unto themselves as people
occasionally are and were voted in
as this then it's completely wrong that
they should be in this council with
absolutely no voice on any committee and
if that is the case then the maths are
wrong and they should be redone
um
thank you councillor connor
everyone is elected individually onto
the council and members opt to form
groups which assist in their
representation every member has a right
to attend any council meeting any
meeting of any committee and and to
speak uh so councillor patch will have a
voice on planning but he won't have as a
vote because he's not a member uh and
the calculations follow the local
government regulations uh and this is
what they work out as uh so chairman i
again ask that the question is put and
we support the committee allocation as
set out thank you all right now council
patch this is going to be the last
injured you you've said several pieces
on this so please the last time
thank you for your patience chair um i
just wanted to say that um i i'm not um
particularly keen on this matter being
pressed of me um going on the planning
committee um any any further in this
discussion i just would however like
like some clarification with regard to
the um the point made about 1 47th of a
counsellor
position and then how that translated
into councillor eden having a place on
the planning committee
in that regard when she was alone
independent
thank you councillor patch um
could i ask the managing director
perhaps too
to be fair i haven't got the
spreadsheets with me in front of me now
but i will provide quite happily provide
counsellor patch with the evidence and
the reasons why
um after this meeting okay we're not
we're not going to go any further with
this debate i think we've had the motion
requested to be put several times uh so
cancer conor has proposed this can i
have a secondary please
cancer dewhirst
oh councilman already seconded that's
fine so
all those in favor
the amendment was
the patch
b
allocated a spot on the planning
committee it was seconded by councillor
malone
right okay we will go to the vote i
thought we had but we will go to the
vote the amendment that um councillor
patches is put on the committee uh all
those in favor that councillor patch is
put on the committee
against
abstentions
that's not
carried so we move to the main motive
which is that the seat allocation as
proposed by cancer connet and seconded
by councillor mcgregor can we go to the
vote please
all those in favor
against
abstentions
thank you that is carried
thank you very much
we now move on to the final two items
and as i notified at almost the
beginning we are swapping around item 18
and 19 so we take item 19 first which is
notices of motion
and they are presented in the order that
they came to the council so can i
ask councillor swain to present his
notice of motion
thank you chair
as we all know the constitution was
tidied up last year i'm very grateful to
councillor patch for spending the time
to compare the versions and flag up the
changes
at the last meeting we were urged not to
nod through these changes
and i agree that these changes are
important and the allegations are very
important because of the uncertainty
surrounding the old version many of my
colleagues along with myself voted to
accept the new version but ensure that
any material changes would be reversed
um i've now had time to look carefully
at the
both versions and the changes that have
been made and i find that in two cases
there have been material changes which
could affect
the rights of the public and councillors
previously the public could ask
questions relevant to the business of
the council this was changed to the
business of the meeting
and a power has been removed for a group
leader to insist that a change to the
constitution is major if others claim
it's minor
um
i also find that valuable opportunity to
update the language was missed so i
bring this motion proposing that the
monitoring officer be asked to produce a
form of words that restores these two
powers and substitutes non-sexist
language throughout the constitution the
revisions should come back to full
council for approval i'm happy for this
to be referred immediately to the
constitution committee thank you chad
thank you councillor swain so i so
propose that we um move this straight to
the procedures committee um
for further debate and then to come back
to this
full council at a later date councillor
patch
i'll be brief chair i'd just like to
request um
through an amendment if that's necessary
the wonder procedures committee look at
this they look at the full list of um
six points can i just interrupt there
councillor patch i understand where
you're coming with this and
as we're going to
have a procedures committee any
recommendations or considerations that
you want to put that
procedures committee for discussion
we're quite happy for you to do that for
a discussion on on your full list so
that is fine
okay country parker calm
majority before debating this
yeah i apologize so do we have a
two-thirds majority all those in favor
that we do debate this
okay just just finish that off
those against debating
so we will not have a debate on it right
so it's going to procedures that is it
point of order right
just a clarification i believe
councillor swain asked for it to go to
the constitutional committee you've said
procedure so i wanted to know which one
it's going to it is the procedures
committee
yeah okay
councillor patch
please this this it's not about the same
item because this
a point of clarification i do i am sorry
chair um just to follow up counselor
parker khan's point um has the
constitution working group been
disbanded now that the procedures
committee has been set up that was the
group that was looking at constitutional
issues before short answer is yes
has been disbanded because it is now the
procedures committee was a decision
effect taken and noted in any minutes of
the meetings of this council it was
it actually wasn't a formulated
committee it was just a working party
okay so it wasn't a proper committee
please if you keep
interrupting i am going to because i've
said so many times to you and you still
keep coming back i'm going to adjourn
the meeting
please
please
if you do not be silent i shall suspend
the meeting during the meeting again
last opportunity for you to be silent
please
you've been pre-warned what might happen
so please
thank you
i've got where we got to now
that has been passed so
that is going to procedures committing
right next second
notice a motion can i pass the leader
for his notice of motion please
chairman i'm quite happy for this to be
referred to appropriate committee but
clearly with the current uh concerns
around
kovid and
the new
variant
the request to government in particular
about
reintroducing virtual meetings is really
important for all members and members of
the public shown it can work well in the
past but i encourage the council's
support i'm very happy for this to go to
committee for further consideration then
come back
thank you
so i would defer this straight on to the
executive committee
so that will happen as from now
thank you if we move on now to the third
notice of motion that is from counselor
mcgregor put your hand up counselor
there no one knows where you are
should do
thank you chair um
this this matter i believe is a matter
for full council and it's not for any um
other committee so uh my
my view would be that it would be
automatic for debate here and we
wouldn't need to two-thirds threshold
for that
in terms of the motion it is as
disclosed in the agenda but i would like
to provide a bit of reasoning uh behind
my decision to raise it and put it
before
my fellow councillors
this motion is not about personalities
or a vendetta but it will be portrayed
as such no doubt by those i'm critically
backing council of connie's position
i'm not here because i want to replace
him as leader or shoehorn myself back
into the lib dem group i present this
motion to you all because of a
fundamental principle
that we must reject physical violence
in the political forum in in fact any
forum
on the 20th of september this year we
saw councillor taylor enter into a
physical altercation with another
councillor
that physical altercation is a matter of
record councillor taylor did grab the
other councillor did try to drag him
from where he was standing and from the
recording still seen afterwards
he had at one point a clenched fist and
set jaw whilst holding on to the other
counselor he also offered councillor
malone out a euphemism for going outside
for a fight
um
as heard by other councillors
whatever you think of councillor malone
or his colleagues
in the manner in which they conduct
themselves it is not ever the place of
another councillor in this case
councillor taylor to turn vigilante and
bouncer and to grapple with council
malone
as a reminder councillor connet the
monitoring officer and others at the
time councillor taylor is not employed
to or expected to intervene he is not a
security guard has no training and no
qualification such as an sia card
why then did councillor connet rush not
only to praise the protagonist
but to attack and insult the victim
counselor conor rushed to the papers to
rescue his political friend demonstrates
not merely poor leadership but poor
conflict management dreadful bias and
very poor judgment
what a shame councillor conor did not
exercise leadership skills and swiftly
organize an unreserved apology
notwithstanding the apology that we
receive today
and condemnation of acts of physical
violence in the chamber at the first
opportunity
that would have closed this down at the
time
however by leaving councillor taylor's
actions uncriticized by in fact praising
councillor taylor's vigilantism
councillor connor is not just condoning
violence he is promoting it
in a world that has increased levels of
vitriol and abuse leveled at politicians
and following the brutal murder of david
amos mp it seems a strange thing to have
to point out to counselor connie a
seasoned counselor that physical
violence is simply not acceptable
what message are we sending out to the
community what impression are we giving
to teenagers and children at school
the 19th century sociologist
cooley wrote everything that i say or
think is influenced by what others have
said or thought and in one way or
another sends out an influence of its
own in turn
we do not operate in the silo what
happens in here transfers outside
my message is that people are influenced
by the observable and experienced world
so condoning violence in here
council econo risks a dangerous
consequence
that the community in which we serve
decide that physical violence is
condoned and therefore acceptable which
it is clearly not
more than three women a week are
murdered by men in this country a week
thousands more are victims of violence
some of which leads to permanent
life-changing injuries and extreme short
trauma for their children trauma which
leads often to lifelong mental health
crises
within the last few months we have seen
a gunman go on a shooting spree in devon
a young woman abducted and murdered in
devon a 12 year old murdered in
liverpool that's just a tiny tip of the
iceberg of violence that we see on a
day-to-day basis we
must demonstrate a zero tolerance to
physical acts of aggression we must
certainly not normalize or worse as
councillor connor has done praise and
instigator of what in my literal view
was an assault
i was elected to serve my community and
that of the wider team bridge district
not merely helping people with their
issues but setting a positive example
condoning councillors councillor
taylor's act of physical violence as
councillor conor has done achieves none
of these things violence tears
communities apart causes untold
suffering and often leaves victims
behind it is essential we are clear that
there is no there is a line that should
not be crossed in terms of physical
violence
the idea that you can condone violence
and vigilantism against an elected
politician in one statement then as
councillor connor has done a few weeks
later published a call to action that we
reduce violence and abuse towards
politicians seems a further example of
counsel conor's poor judgment if not a
hypocritical position to take
it had been
claimed by councillor connet
john nutley and councillor wrigley who
is setting up a workforce to prevent
violence that councillor taylor's attack
was both a good thing and preemptive
well unless these three male counsellors
are mind readers their view has no
validity you might as well say i punched
her before she could hit me
we're all used to newton says no ranting
pacing about and ignoring the chair
but the only person ever to introduce
physical aggression in this chamber is
actually gary taylor councillor taylor i
therefore ask my colleagues to consider
this not from party lines not personal
likes or dislikes but to look at the
violence actually committed the poor
judgment that followed and continues
throughout the subsequent weeks and
months
vote not along party lines but in
recognition that a vote in support of
alan conner's leader would quite simply
be a vote for spontaneous violence for
vigilantism and for physical abuse of
elected politicians
the council must be clear
to its communities that having zero
tolerance of acts of violence means
having zero tolerance to acts of
physical violence thank you
[Applause]
thank you councillor mcgregor now
before we go any further he's quite
right in saying there is no real
committee for this to be referred to but
it's the the
realization that we need two-thirds of
this council to vote for debate on this
item so i'm going to go go to that and
ask if there is a
willingness within the council to debate
that we need two-thirds
of the council to debate this
you need five
there is five right okay fine so we'll
have a recorded vote as to whether this
goes debate
can i ask you to call it the names
please sarah
connet
counselor cook
counsellor cook
she's having difficulty hearing
you know
i'm sorry we don't want comments like
that please
counselor david cox
councillor hugh cox
councillor dawes
counselor dewhurst
councillor eden
council goodman bradbury
councillor gribble
councillor hayes
councillor hayes
councillor hawking
councillor gordon hook
councillor jackie hook
counselor jeffrey
councillor jeffries
councillor jenks
councillor keeling
councillor kurzweil
councillor mcgregor
councillor morgan
council malone
councillor netsley
councillor nuttall
council parker khan
councillor patch
councillor john petterick
councillor linda pederick
councillor phipps
council rollerson
councillor russell
councillor swain
councillor taylor
councillor team
council wrigley
councillor evans
councillor parker against
can we have the numbers please when you
can
we did not get the two-thirds so that
will not be going to debate
can i have silence please silence please
i i have a raised hand cancer bullet
thank you a question of clarification if
i may
this council operates under its
constitution
the constitution has been enforced for
43 years
never in 43 years
has a notice of motion come forward like
this
excuse me
we have in front of us to make a
decision an accusation against the
leader
about the vote of no confidence there is
no procedure defined within our
constitution that actually tells us what
or how it should be handled
the vote of requiring
three quarters to vote in favor against
predetermined a decision against the
vote of no confidence and for that
reason i would ask through the chair
if this isn't something
that should be referred back to the
procedures committee to define a process
and procedure that is appropriate in
these circumstances
secondly
we've had a notice
through the procedures
which allows the person making
the notice of motion to make a case
what we haven't and our procedures
currently do not allow it
is for the respondent in this case as i
said the first time in 43 years an
individual has been pointed out and
accused of things can i ask the
indulgence of the chair and ask that we
allow the leader
to make a statement in response the
allegations made against him
right thank you cancer bulovan i
understand what he says regarding this
being
perhaps looked at at procedures and
that's something that we can consider so
if you're making that suggestion we will
certainly look at it
um
right counselor
sorry during the the vote counselor
clearly voted against debating it so i
think i suggest that he surrendered his
uh opportunity to um make a comment um
i'm sorry i'm going to disallow that
because i've been asked by another
member whether he would
like the opportunity to come back and
i'm going to allow him to make a comment
i feel it's justified for him to make a
comment
[Music]
right so what's the point of order then
basically the order is that you're
acting unconstitutionally what council
mcgregor said is correct this is not to
be debated and favors cannot be given uh
to to uh councillors in in the way that
you you're showing as chair this is
totally and utterly unconstitutional
chairman i would seek to exercise my
right to make a personal statement and
view what's being said
there there is no debate but an
allegation has been made by one
individual against another and i think
in this there's nothing in the
constitution about this so there's in a
sense of natural justice it is only
correct that the leader be allowed to
make a reply
of point of order in the constitution if
a councillor is accused personally he
has a right to have and he shall be
heard against all others he shall be
heard that he to give a personal
statement that is in the constitution
people going on about the constitution
being changed that is in the
constitution live by the constitution
i think we have answered that can we
please i'm going to adjourn the meeting
if you have one more outsmarts at the
back is going to be adjourned this is
the last warning
counselor connect
would you like to make a personal
comment i would thank you chairman thank
you
thank you chairman
thank you for the opportunity to respond
the key tasks of this council are
headlined in the three overarching
priorities homes to those who need them
creating and protecting jobs tackling
climate change i want to thank all of
our staff for the excellent work they
are doing and to help us achieve those
goals and maintaining our day-to-day
services
as councillors we draw our authority
from the people who elect us we have all
done we all have one thing in common we
have polled at least one vote more than
the person who wasn't elected
the council leader draws their authority
from the council you
in turn the executive members under the
council's constitution draw their
authority from a leader
as individual counsellors we are each
responsible for our own actions and
behaviour
i welcome councillor taylor's apology to
the council earlier in this meeting i
too have apologized to council after a
councillor felt a comment i had made was
not appropriate
some
some counselors though choose not to
apologize
some arm themselves with their own sword
of truth and seek to protect themselves
with a shield of openness honesty and
transparency
let's take a closer look chairman
one councillor declares they own two
properties and yet i'm told the land
registry shows them to be in someone
else's name
one counsellor
one
chairman i'm entitled to speaking to be
heard is please
can you
this
counselor
is allowed to speak german i'm entitled
to speak
please can we german refrain one
councillor
one councillor declares they own two
properties and yet i am told the land
registry shows them to be in someone
else's name
one
one councillor appears
one councillor appears not to declare
the property in the district that they
actually live in
one councillor
can you be quiet please one counselor
have made two applications to the
cambridge planning service this year and
on each has declared they are not a
counsellor
one counselor
one counselor declares themselves to be
a company director but a simple check at
company's house appears to show the
company was dissolved earlier this year
are these are these significant matters
you decide
however
these same councils hold others to a
standard they themselves appear not to
want to observe
each counselor is responsible for
declaring their register of interests
it is there for a reason and if a
councillor chooses not to disclose their
property interest then does that does it
not lead to the questions what other
land or interests are they not declared
what other associations are kept secret
from the public gays
chairman we have all been elected
equally we do and will all disagree on
matters we can conduct the life of the
council with civility and focus on the
things that matter most the services we
provide for our customers which help and
support them in their daily lives thank
you chairman
thank you
is is that it can't look on it thank you
that that is it
no there's no further debate on this
this is actually
councillor malone would you please sit
down
please
i'm going to adjourn the
meeting the meeting is adjourned